sputter its back in the MCU all right
yes star-lord - we're gonna watch
awkward [ __ ] official one saw the
teaser a while ago Tom Hall and Chris
Pratt United with Julia louis-dreyfus
that's what we've been truly waiting for
[Music]
oh this is gonna be
[Music]
Oh oh my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's see that going so it's like ad
astra with Elle's kind of in a
roundabout way where's the couch tomato
video I like the plot setup of this the
world of it I wonder like the first part
of it is gonna be you know a lot of
those jokes kind of like from the movie
bright yeah it's like we're gonna
introduce ourselves to the society and
here's every way in which magical
creature fits in and some of them are
kind of like common pests and stuff
which we've already seen the teaser with
the unicorns and then we got these
little like I don't know what those
little tiny like troll characters biker
dudes like well I feel like the first
hand
30 minutes will probably be a lot of the
kind of jokes that you would see in a
movie like bright or Shrek
yeah or Shrek and then I think when they
get on the adventure the actual road
trip that looks actually kind of dark
it looks like it's funny but the
creature designs they're going with soon
that'd be a lot of the medieval kind of
mystical creatures yeah you're exploring
throughout like with the biker gang like
at that alternate chuck-e-cheese or
something the world looks very cool to
me and actually there was the darker
side stuff that looked more appealing to
me when they're in the convenience store
and you got the little evil fairies
looks like they're robbing the place
where they're just annoying customers or
something yeah I mean if they're like
you gather is that they're a biker gang
wreaking havoc on that place and like
stealing Yanks and whatever and trying
to pick a fight with dad it looks like
they're not shying away from some of the
darker elements of what the kind of
characters are doing though the creature
specifically that the riff and on it was
just cool to me a journey for too you
know late teenagers to go on like it
might have like that than I expected
pigs are moving to be quote edgy but
this looks like it could have maybe a
little bit more but
age edge around it you know especially
because they're both over 16 now you
know they're like almost dholtze yeah
yes stuff and I'm onward to they go to
the strip club exactly man then they're
like no but he's there with his bottom
half that was the most shocking thing to
me about this trailer because just like
as a trailer itself it just confirms
what the logline has been all along
which is you know they didn't ever get
to know their dad really so they're
gonna get this one day with him put that
a whole detailed about only being able
to bring him back half way at first yes
such a weird like side quest to throw in
here or weird rigor that that's what's
fast well you the money he's a ticking
clock John they got 24 hours to bring
him back so they could spend one day
with him knowing their luck that they're
gonna spend 24 hours I'll bring him back
they're gonna get one minute of actual
time with him is it is it the rule you
get 24 hours to bring the rest of him
back no I think it's just you get 24
hours to bring him back but although I
don't know what the movies gonna say
about that maybe the movies gonna pull
some kind of thing worth it oh you guys
I'm gonna get that much time cuz you
brought it back half way so technically
you still okay here maybe that'll be a
moral thing maybe they'll learn by the
end that it's not about seeing their dad
they never knew again maybe I just have
a feeling we're all gonna cry at some
point especially when the dad comes back
and he's like I never loved you - yeah I
didn't want to be come back I didn't
want to ever be your father
half of me has been pulled out of the
afterlife on this adventure and now all
of me has finally pulled out and I
started a family with another woman and
we have way more children and those
children far exceed they're all
celebrities amal distinguished
themselves in really important ways and
as an accountant i was able to a
significantly profit off of our family's
financial disaster but i learned a lot
the Chris Pratt Tom Holland chemistry
here feels very palpable you know this
seems like the kind of movie were behind
the scenes are making up with it but it
looks like Chris Pratt and Tom hollow
we're probably in the same room when
they were doing this socially because so
much of their scenes are together it
looks like we're there bantering with
one another and I just imagined that
they would probably have to be in the
same room to record for these scenes and
you could really feel that chemistry
being brought to life I always find it
funny when these famous celebrities who
are not American are brought on board to
do American accents for a voice is great
for it and you know he's a wonderful
actor expressive yeah so you and you
could you could hear like yeah it's
definitely tom hollander pretty much
definitely I did gets a weekend at
Bernie's vibes in a weird way with
having to keep him alive like yeah I
feel like that's the most interesting
stuff about this trailer to me is that
weekend at Bernie's element and just
yeah how kind of dark their take on
fairytale world kind of looks because as
much as it is fanciful it's clearly a
version of this where we're all kind of
used to it and it's not rundown but you
know they're like airplanes and cars and
mermaids are chillin in pools and like
no it's not as fanciful as it could be
so I wonder yeah how they're gonna
handle their world cuz again that's one
of the things that's gonna make this
distinct or not incase you kids don't
know weekend at Bernie's is about a guy
who died on a guy who died during a
Bernie Sanders right yeah it was really
sad cuz you really believed in those
progressive ideals that's all you got to
know children that's right politics
alright guys well thanks for being here
y'all can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell what do you
think of onward leave it in the comments
below or directly message John on
Twitter that's right before we wrap this
up I'd like to give a page from the day
shout out to a man named Jake Stewart
Jake my buddy you know what's gonna
happen is I'm gonna go to Illinois and
you and I we're gonna take a road trip
so you and I could go watch a joker for
the third time Oh together and cuddle up
in pure depression
because that's the way I like to bond
with any patron or subscriber is through
sadness and tears because that level of
remorse guilt vulnerability that's what
bonds us buddy mm-hmm just like how
these brothers are gonna be going
through a lot of pain on this emotional
journey
opening up grief you and I we're gonna
experience a hell of a lot of pain
together from the heart it's hard for
two guys to let their walls down and you
know just a bro a way but without being
too macho about it no macho this time
but there will be nachos because we'll
be at the theater watching Joker and we
won't be playing poker Oh popcorn all
right and your midnight talker